[Applause]
believed to be just 14.
the bullet has pierced his head
you can hear the panic as desperate
protesters try to get him to an
ambulance
he doesn't survive
in mandalay guns and tear gas are also
being fired at protesters
19 year old jason is trying to stay low
everything will be okay her t-shirt
promises
but the bullets keep on coming
so now jael's family must bury her no
money
it was not done accidentally because of
her height we assume she was targeted
[Music]
around the country the death toll and
injuries keep on rising
the junta's crackdown is increasingly
brutal
here the man in white being led away by
police
appears to be shot
his body is kicked later
dragged off they started to shoot with
the mortar again
not only with the rifle they shoot with
the motor again
and i hear that
they treat the pro texture very brutally
you don't need to beat
to the people who lie on the ground
right but
they do the beat to the people
who's lying on the ground
[Applause]
a month after the coup myanmar's
military is doing what it can to crush
the resistance
how many more will die on these streets
which are fast becoming battlefield
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok